hey if you let's support the production
of more move university video tutorials
then please visit the support move
section on Luke universe comm thank you
and enjoy
so these lipoproteins have obviously
protein components to them and some of
the more important things to consider
about these proteins is the fact that
there are April proteins or April
lipoproteins these specific proteins
that are important in kind of realizing
and helping with helping you understand
what's going on with the functions of
these lipoproteins these proteins do
specific things and because they do
specific things that kind of helps you
understand what's going on with the
lipoproteins so there are a bunch and
this is this is definitely not all of
them these are some of the main ones but
the ones that I'm going to be talking
about specifically are highlighted in
green so let's get to it scroll down
just a bit
alright so a protein a one made in the
intestine in the liver its main
lipoprotein partners the HDL and it this
is coming from Mike from chylomicrons
it's important function is activating L
cap which is left lecithin cholesterol
acyl transferase what this does is it
actually makes cholesterol esters it
makes cholesterol esters which we saw in
the previous video can be done by a cat
but L cat does it in a slightly
different way that we'll see later when
we actually talk about HDL particles and
also form the structure of HDL a PO b48
made in the intestine is partnered up
with chylomicrons is actually unique to
chylomicrons is only April B 48 is only
found in chylomicrons so that's an
important thing to note and it's
basically important in in assembly and
secretion of chylomicrons from the small
intestine in order for chylomicrons to
do their function and delivering dietary
lipids to the in the body a PO be 100
made in the liver is partnered up with
VLDL IDL and LDL it's important of
course in making VLDL and secreting it
it is a structural portion of all three
of these and that's actually an
important thing
keep in mind as well and one thing
that's really really key is that this a
w100 binds the LDL receptor so I'll put
a couple stars by that actually three of
them that's really important because
well you'll see later that this is this
is a really really important idea here a
post c2 which is a component of
chylomicrons VLDL IDL HDL basically
everything except the LDL it's really
important because it activates LPL which
is three stars next to that and that's
super important LPL is lipoprotein
lipase which basically takes
triglycerides and cleaves them into
fatty acids plus glycerol so that's
something that we'll find to be super
important in fact I'm going to put
another star here by LDX that's pretty
important as well a PO a here I'm in the
liver part of chylomicron remnants the
LDL ideal HDL it's really important as a
ligand for binding the LDL receptor as
well as the apoE receptor right here we
have written LDL receptor related
protein that's also important but I
don't think I'm gonna talk about that
very much because I'm going to go over a
general overview of these different
lipoproteins
and also it's important in because it
can bind these receptors ISM it's
important in the clearance of the
chylomicron remnants as well as VLDL
remnants which is basically the ideal so
this is important as well so I want you
to keep these in mind especially these
these ones in green when we're talking
about the lipoproteins because it will
help you understand what's going on okay
so I hope that video was helpful as a
brief introduction to these lipoprotein
or to these April lipoproteins or April
proteins and hopefully I'll see you the
next video thanks for watching thanks
for watching be sure to LIKE comment
subscribe and don't forget to share the
video of anyone who you think might find
it helpful thanks and happy studying